Have you heard anything about cilantro being a good natural key later?
So this is this points back to your ability to go back to you have access to all these
courses.
The seven phases of detox course right here is where we talk about the seven phases of detox.
So we talk about the when you talk about a key later key lation is what I call phase zero
in the seven phases of detoxification and I go through the best detoxers for key lation
to key late.
You have to make sure all your other six phases are open and you're at least working on
those before you start any key lation.
But certainly cilantro is a good key later now cilantro would be classified as a mild key
later and I write much about that in the seven phases of detox book.
You really can't hurt yourself with cilantro you know even if you work dealing with some
other phases of detox at the same time.
I started adding cilantro to my green smoothie daily just in case figured it couldn't hurt.
Yes I would be with you 100% on that there really isn't any downside to cilantro cilantro
is a food and a person could have a food sensitivity to cilantro but it's not very common that
would be the only thing so long for that.
But cilantro is a great very mild key later.